welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video are
breaking down Star Wars Return of the
Jedi
[Music]
filled with Easter eggs hidden details
and lots of things going on with it this
tops off what's arguably one of the
greatest trilogies of all time
throughout this video we're going to be
going through it scene by Cena talk
about all the things you missed as well
as those well-loved special edition
changes
[Music]
coming off the back of two of the
biggest Blockbusters of all time George
Lucas had the galaxy in the palm of his
hands but he was faced with the almost
impossible task of sticking the landing
for a film series that had completely
changed Cinema I know looking back
people tend to complain about the Ewoks
and how Luke's chaba's plan makes no
sense but when I watched this as a kid I
never had any problems with it I guess
I've been lucky in that because of my
love for it none of the criticisms ever
bothered me and it's still a movie that
I absolutely adore I think the biggest
problem with the movie is that it
unfortunately had the difficult task of
following A New Hope an Empire which
demios does some of the best films ever
made now Empire was of course a massive
success and at that point it was one of
the highest grossing films of all time
most impressive a sequel was quickly put
into production with Lucas and financing
the entire thing continuing to remain as
a producer Lucas began searching for
directors with him initially approaching
longtime friend Steven Spielberg by due
to issues with the Directors Guild Lucas
unfortunately had his hands tied the
filmmaker found himself unexpectedly
mired in Hollywood politics
to preserve the dramatic opening
sequences of his films Lucas wanted the
screen credits to come at the end of the
movies it was a highly unusual choice
and for the first Star Wars The Writer's
Guild and Director's Guild had allowed
it but when Lucas did the same for the
sequel they fined him over a quarter of
a million dollars and even attempted to
pull Empire from theaters
next the DGA went after Irvin kirschner
to protect his director Lucas paid all
the fines to the guilds but the
situation left him feeling frustrated
and persecuted
Lucas was so upset that he dropped out
of the Director's Guild
The Writer's Guild
and the Motion Picture Association thus
Spielberg was unable to do it and Lucas
turned back to David Lynch again he
apparently approached him for Empire but
he still felt his style was too distant
from what Lucas wanted and David
Cronenberg also declined the job
eventually settling on Richard Marquand
it's actually thought that Lucas
somewhat ghost-directed the film due to
marquan's inexperience with special
effects at one point Richard joked it
was like trying to direct King Lear with
Shakespeare in the Next Room as Lucas
was on set for a large part of the
production a German Empire he was in the
process of setting up ilm and a number
of different Production Studios so he
wasn't physically able to be on set as
much however man now had way more free
time and this was the case in the
writing too working once more with
Lawrence kazden the screenplay was
created with the original title being
Return of the Jedi before was then
switched to Revenge George came to me
and he said the title of episode
six
is uh
Return of the Jedi
and I said
I think it's a weak title and it came
back one or two days later and he says
we're calling it a revenge of the Jedi
how about this idea of Revenge it never
sat right with Lucas he felt like
Revenge was against the Jedi way and
thus it went back to the original before
the film hit Cinemas and they also had a
bit of an issue with Harrison 4 that was
a carryover from Empire though Mark
Hamill and Carrie Fisher sign on for the
sequels they never actually got four to
agree to them bring him back for Empire
had been a bit of a negotiation and he
actually wanted her to get killed off in
the Carbonite scene his status as an
actor had also risen with Indiana Jones
and Lucas even went into cracking the
screenplay with the idea that there was
no way he was going to come back however
Howard kazanjin got lucky when dealing
with his Agent Phil Gersh who was on
vacation at the time of the negotiations
when Howard called up the agency it was
luckily as sunnyvan said and together
the pair then negotiate the deal so
David his son he he saved Star Wars and
he's a bloody bloody blue top bloke now
Phil wasn't too happy when he got back
and he thought they'd taken advantage of
his son but solo was on Lock and he was
then added to the script anyway both
Ford and kazden thought that solo should
be killed early on in the movie and this
would put some Stakes into the rest of
the film I thought Han Solo should die I
thought he ought to sacrificed himself
for the other two characters I also felt
someone had to go
I felt someone had to die I said he's
got no Mama He's got no papa he's got no
future he has no
um story responsibilities at this point
so let's uh allow him to commit
self-sacrifice this would happen during
a ride on endo and then Luke would end
up like alone Gunslinger on the solo
hero avaluka shut down the idea and it
has been thought this was done how many
Han Solo toys they'd managed to sell
over the last couple of years board said
Lucas didn't see a feature in that hunt
eyes and the solo stayed alive until the
end of the film and the Ewoks were also
originally rookies but I'm guessing
those toy sales made Lucas change his
mind to make something cuter yodo's also
someone who was completely absent from
the film but director Richard Marquan
felt like they needed to bring things
full circle from the prior movie Lucas
also saw this as an opportunity to
confirm Vader was indeed Luke's father
as many suspected The Twist at the end
of empire was actually a lie this
included James owns who didn't believe
they were related until he sat down and
read the script for return now
production began at L Street Studios
with a movie occupying nine sets with a
budget of 32.5 million Lucas actually
saved roughly 18 million by using his
own company ilm to carry out the special
effects given the working title Blue
Harvest will not will not do a weekly
planet and this was due to the
production feeling like they were being
ripped off because of the success of the
prior movies it was assumed that
lucasfilm had enough money to build an
actual death star and thus they
constantly got overcharged when they
went out to buy things for the film
people felt like they could invoice more
because the company could afford it
unless they created the working title to
keep it out the public Eye Blue Harvest
film from January to main 1982 being a
shoot that was six years short of an
Empire this allowed ilm to get way more
time to work on the effects including a
massive space battle at the end which
would culminate on a richly detailed set
of tunnels in the second death star and
the movie also ended up leading to the
creation of THX due to some test
screenings failing to Output several
other sound effects and themes in the
movie thus Lucas did the old if you want
to do something you've got to do it
yourself and he implemented THX which
became a staple in the industry all in
all the entire Saga not only changed a
lot of things for Lucas but it also
changed a lot of things for Cinema in
general now the movie begins with the
usual text crawl but there's a slight
difference to what's come before and
what followed the crawl ends with three
Ellipsis scissors whereas in every other
title crawl it ends with four this was
actually put in place because Lucas
wanted to leave us with the idea there'd
be no other films after this though he
did have ideas of doing three trilogies
at the time Lucas also said he was
inspired by Lord of the Rings and its
third iteration Return of the King which
he felt was a fitting way to close
things out I like a lot of Star Wars
titles there's a layered meaning to this
one with the titular Jedi more likely
being a reference to Anakin rather than
being Luke Luke never really went away
and thus the returning Jedi here makes
more sense when you think of it as being
Anakin now you can of course apply to
Luke as well and the first sentence of
the crawl talks about how lucra turned
to his home planet the idea of returning
is also a staple of Joseph Campbell's
Heroes Journey which we've talked about
in these breakdowns before Luke went
through all the steps beat by beating
the trilogy with the final stage being
the return we've also seen this
reflected in this color scheme
throughout with his clothing going from
white to black across the three films in
a new hope he'll cause War wide which
changed to gray when he got to Empire
come return he's dressed in all black
and fans at the time thought this might
show he'd actually turned to the dark
side when the original screenwriting
process for the movie began they did toy
with the idea of making him turn evil
and we'd then wonder if he turned back
again which ties into the idea of the
return elements of this are still
apparent in the film with Luke arriving
in a dark silhouette akin to Vader
showing up on the tantive foreign A New
Hope all that the flap on the front of
the uniform evangi folds down
symbolically showing Allah Lighter Side
within him now speaking of A New Hope
before Force awakens basically became a
remake of it this movie actually did a
lot of the elements of the film for
example we start on Tatooine and have
another death star with the emperor saw
of being a switch out of talking even
the opening shots almost look exactly
the same and we have a star destroyer
coming into view from the exact same
angle blow it is a planet and off in the
distance we can see the Death Star which
has replaced the original moonshot again
it's sort of like poetry they rhyme and
we see Veda arriving on the second death
star smoke comes down off the ramp and
it's very similar to Cloud that also
surrounded him when he stepped through
the door in a new hope these shots will
later Rift on in Ahsoka when Balin and
shinhadi arrived at the new Republic
Cruiser there's lots of things that
Ahsoka actually takes from this film
which I will talk about as well because
it's still fresh in my mind now on the
shuttle we also see the language arabesh
which was created by Lucas after
replacing the original English words in
A New Hope also shuttle comes in I've
just noticed for the first time you can
see a tie bomb parked up in the bottom
of the hangout which we get a clearer
view of in the next shot now on Tatooine
we see C3PO and R2 arriving at Jabba's
Palace which Echoes their Journey
arriving on the planet in A New Hope
learning that Lando and Chewbacca never
return from here this sort of
foreshadows what the next parts of the
plan are chatting with a security guard
that speaks her tease we also get a
vastly expanded front door for the
special editions side by side we can see
how they stretched it out and this was
gonna give the appearance that it was
way more expensive oh that yeah nitpick
when they get inside we can see it's a
lot smaller so I never really got the
point of why they did this in the first
place and that that's mainly with a lot
of the special edition changes in
general anyway we arrived to see jabber
getting found by a Jawa and slowing out
dining on frogs
George said oh I need something that's
you know alien and grotesque it's like
um
like Sydney Green Street
oh okay when I had kind of gotten this
idea down to this big
slug-like thing that is just this big
pulsating mass of Flesh at one point I
did put I put I had a fez on one of the
characters like Cindy Green Street and
then Stuart Freeborn in England his job
was to fabricate the thing and that was
operated with the one Puppeteer for each
arm two puppeteers for the arms another
guy doing the head another guy radio
control guy do any highs there's like a
couple little people in it you know
pulling things to make the tail move
around it was quite a thing jabo's
lighter added into the special editions
of a new Hub with Lucas originally
planning to include him he had to get
these scenes because of time and money
which was rectified when they had the
resources to finally put him in he's
joined by bib Fortuna and this is a
character that would later go on to take
over the throne set by Jabba is also the
quacking monkey lizard salacious crumb
who Lucas wanted to be sort of the
equivalent of a laughing Court Jester
for EPO and R2 have come to deliver a
message from Luke which I always loved
growing up as a kid it's something that
these days we see Denzel doing all the
time in the Eco equalizer movies and I
love how he's basically just saying we
don't have to play around and find
out just give me harm back and you can
crawl away from this it's so badass but
we watch as he rejects this and the
droids are taken to the cells that lie
beneath the palace we see a Gunk Droid
being tortured and also catch a white
dried against the back wall which 3PO
bangs into this was actually a reuse
prop from the sand crawler and a new hoe
with it being in the corner when 3PO and
R2 talk and we see Jabba dancing away to
the max rebelt band who ended up
returning in the book of Boba Fett the
musical number here was originally quite
scaled back with a puppet of snice
noodles not really operating that well
any shots though you can catch Landau
before they updated the performance for
the special editions please
[Music]
[Applause]
disguise with later brought into solo
with Woody Harrelson's character back at
wearing it and leaving it on the Falcon
for Lando to then find the news also
apologies and I'm Gonna Keep referencing
movies that come down the line but I
feel like if I don't Point them out then
I'm I'm personally going to go insane
being like I should have just mentioned
that I shouldn't have been scared either
way Joe he has I'm sorry guys I know you
hate them either way Joe yazzo was added
into these as well with his vocal
performance being based on Joe Cocker
[Music]
written by John Williams son Joseph
Williams he was also a lead member in
the band Toto at the song is titled
lapti neck which translates into hatis
to mean work it out you can also catch a
flying mic flying around the backup
singers and I have to admit this song it
always makes me tap my feet
this man
the dancer Oola is dropped into the
rancor pit with her backstory being
pretty dark
ulo was part of the Twilight clan on
ryloth before she was basically
kidnapped and trafficked by bip Fortuna
Jabba demonstrates his callous disregard
for life with Euler and at this point
plan B's put in place we hear a gunshot
and then catch a rhodian spinning round
who ends up standing behind C3PO as he
asks this
what did I say
this guy was actually wearing the same
vessel Leia had on during the start of
Empire Strikes Back which I I kind of
feel like as the people on this set
giving us a clue that this is actually
here might be a reach but yeah she
arrives disguised as the Bounty Hunter
Bush and in a bit of behind the scenes
info the numbers one one three eight are
etched into a helmet which you can see
in the photographs of it this is the nod
to Lucas's film THX 1138 and this
numbers appeared in all the trilogy
movies so far
now upon whipping out a thermal that
night out he watches Boba Fett draws his
gun and they actually had to flip this
shot so it looked like he was aiming in
the right place the antenna on the heads
normally on the other side but they
found it didn't match up with the way he
walked off so they ended up spinning it
around now after a shot of the Wharton
binary sunsets we see Leia approaching
the Carbonite case as Jabba's crew
seemingly sleeps in the top left we can
see a Taunton head hanging up which of
course would be a rare item on it as a
planet I love how in the curtains drawn
you can also see a grand with their hand
over 3po's mouth and this is so that he
doesn't show and try and warn his
friends player is grabbed and she ends
up wearing a metallic bikini that fueled
a lot of teenage fantasies for for most
of people my age most of the life that
this stuck with you and meant to Echo
Flash Gordon once more with Jebel later
saying she'd come to appreciate him
which was supposed to reference Ming the
merciless forcing dala Den to marry him
as for her bikini there were actually
two versions of this made with the
second being rubber so that Carrie could
move about easier this is what they whip
out during most of the action scenes and
it was due to how uncomfortable that the
metallic one was the garage at this
point and we get further teasers that he
might be turning evil due to him Force
choking the guards which is a signature
Vader move using the Jedi mind trick he
gets bib to take him directly to jabber
but we actually see through jabber that
those who are mentally strong don't fall
Folly to it you will like the like
button and he's dropped into the pit
where he comes face to face with the
rancor who he defeats by throwing a
skull at a door switch I always saw this
was a rock but nope slow it down and you
can actually see this as a human skull
which belonged to the character bildo
quiv there's actually a big backstory
that's been written for them because it
wouldn't be Star Wars if they didn't
have an expensive backstory and they
carry the moniker of having the most
important skull in the Galaxy the ranko
Batista is killed and we see we see my
man go it does
[Music]
now in the expanded law William patisser
actually saved his life and the pair
have bonded ever since then the bad
batch told us about the sacred bond that
rancors have with their owners and this
was explored in an episode when the
batch got a young Rancor named muchi for
Jabba originally intended to be a man in
his suit they ended up using a rod
puppet after the initial effect didn't
seem convincing enough recording Ben
Bits dog Max they created the creature's
signature sound by getting its box and
growls and then pitching them down now
from the other taken to the sarlacc pit
and in the build up to it we see some
migrating banthus they would often get
caught by Tuscan Riders who would use
them as rides like we saw in the first
film and the pit itself was updated to
have a beak-like head for the special
editions as Lucas felt the creature
didn't feel alive enough R2 then gets
into play so he can launch Luke's
lightsaber and Boba Fett's the only
character who notices he's doing this me
I would have sounded the alarm but it
allows Luke to launch his plan to
destroy jabber and his cronies as we see
Jabba's soldiers moving through the
barge I love how you can catch a mural
of Jabba hanging up and it shows the
guys the egos bigger than he is now Boba
Fett of course gets thrown into the
solac pit with him escaping in the
expanded lore and his solo series Lucas
has admitted he still to this day has no
idea where the character became so
popular and kinda regrets not giving him
a more impactful death when working on
the 2004 DVD release he actually planned
him including an extra moment where we
saw fed escape the pit however in the
end he decided against this as he feared
it could tease things that he'd never
get to make Luke's lightsaber is also
green but originally it was planned that
it was gonna be the classic blue if you
go back and look at the posters you can
see this in the marketing showing what
the original plan for the blade was
gonna be however a number of issues
popped up when they made the movie with
the first being that the blue got lost
against the Skies of Tatooine they also
felt that might become Fusion over how
he lost securing Empire and then he
turned back up though us the Nerds would
have been like look at me it's a
completely different lightsaber so what
they did is they had a deleted scene
showing him constructing it but it kind
of slowed the pacing and stopped this
big reveal of it here so Lucas just
settled on it being green and in the
expanded law the original one was then
wielded by a clone of Luke before it was
retaken and given to Luke's wife Mara
Jade uh as the creator of uh wait
I am not the creator of RJ and I want
you to get out of this office right now
I'm sorry no way no way you brought it
on yourself I don't want you here
I'm sorry George I didn't think it would
go like this
out
Dad I got your voucher out so I just had
to come with an excuse to use that clip
because it always cracks me up and I'm a
bit a bit bit of a anyway
there's also a moment where when Boba
Fett flies across the sky and hits the
barge we can see Luke kicking someone in
the foreground the kick is Miles off
from hitting the guy and Mark Hamill is
jokingly said that Luke actually Force
kicked him and the creative team looked
at a lot of swashbuckling pirate movies
in order to craft this scene and there's
definitely that feeling with ropes and
boats being a big thing here Luke is
also made to walk the plank but like a
lot of those pirate films he flips it on
his head
[Music]
Luca is also shot in the hand as well
and this marker later returns at the end
of the force awakens when he takes the
lightsaber off Rey now Billy Williams
didn't come out and skate either and
apparently during the scene in which
hand shoots at the tentacles the Pyro
Technic went off close to his leg and it
ended up burning him his son Corey D
also makes an appearance in the scene as
well with him actually playing one of
Jabba's henchmen C3PO is also attacked
by salacious crumb and this led to
Anthony Daniels having a real-life panic
attack I've got claustrophobia once and
it was I didn't even have the whole suit
on I was lying on the floor the camera
is about that far away from me uh
salacious crumb the wonderful salacious
crumb animated by Tim Rose and he's
pulling out my eyes before I take two
action and something went in my mind I
didn't catch a breath or something and I
suddenly could feel Panic just absorbing
into my body
and I I think get me out get me out get
me out get me out get me out and I just
kept repeating it until they managed to
whiz the head off now is it not to
longtime friend Francis Ford Coppola
Lucas had a layer choke Jabra with their
chains which was supposed to resemble
Luca brazzi's Death In His movie The
Godfather Lucas was actually originally
intoxic now but he ended up exiting it
so that Coppola could take over now
Francis actually left a little not to
him in the movie as the character
Harrison Ford plays is called Colonel G
Lucas the final battle involving the
Ewok saucer bills off the back of
Lucas's original idea for the movie with
the jungle setting riffing off the back
of Vietnam come the end of the battle
they use all manner of Guerrilla tactics
at the disposal with Lucas modeling
these after the Viet Cong anyway they
get out of there before it blows up and
don't forget the droids which gives us a
brilliant Victory to start the movie off
with Han says I owe you one now but like
he owed you two so I would not deduct in
that mate like what's this maths anyway
in his X-Wing we see Luke exam in his
hand which he can covers up by putting a
black glove over it it shuts reference
later on when Luke sees that is missing
one echoing the fact that he could end
up going down that path now at this
point we could to the Death Star and
amongst the fleet of ties we can also
catch Thai interceptors For the First
Time In The Saga the emperor arrives
who's also played for the first time by
Ian McDermott now this blew my mind when
I was doing my research but he was
actually only 39 when he played this pot
yeah he's just seven years older than
Mark Hamill is but I gotta say the man
can play old now according to him he was
just brought in to do a physical
performance similar to what David prowse
did with Darth Vader this was then going
to be redubbed with Clyde Revel who
originally played the character in The
Empire Strikes Back other McDermott
completely knocked it out the park when
delivering his lines and thus they
decided to stick with his performance
which has become iconic now a lot of
these moments where we get the wider
shots were actually made using matte
paintings so what are we looking at here
here is just a wonderful example of all
these Stormtroopers and nobody knows
that it's a map painting you just assume
that this is a very large set
foreign
so there were some real Storm Troopers
on the set and then the rest were added
by The Mad artist Vader also kneels
before him which is a similar thing to
what he did during the hologram scene in
Empire showing who's really in charge
now Luke returns to dagobar where he
comes face to face with Yoda all right
that the guy was just like sick of
answering questions and he'd rather turn
over than die than dealing with more
Skywalker although he does
spell it out that Luke needs to confront
Vader to complete his training and this
word confront carries a lot with it
rather than killing him he just wants to
face his dad because he could be the
person that ends up bringing him back
and knowing what we know about the
prequels I actually think it makes red
Azog better in retrospect in the end his
love for his son is what ends up saving
him and he turns back in order to save
him from the emperor the scene of him
electrocuting Luke also getra played in
Revenge of the Sith with him standing
there and allowing pulps to take out
Mace Windu here he refuses to stand by
and allowed to happen again and I
actually think the prequels improve all
this even though it works well on its
own he also mentions how once Yoda dies
that he'll be the last Jedi which
careful mate we don't talk about that
here now Yoda's last words here also
build off the back of his last words in
the prior film that boy is our last hope
no there is another
guy walk yeah it's in the word Skywalker
which is then clarified outside by
Obi-Wan he explains that Leia is his
twin sister and also how Anakin's death
was caused by Veda because he killed all
that he stood for Alec guinnessoni ended
up shooting for one day for this movie
and we talked last time how he did this
with Empire as well Lucas made a deal
with him yet where he got 0.25 of the
growth of these films and in the end
that netted him 100 million dollars that
adjusted for inflations roughly 400
million dollars meaning that he shot the
stuff for a New Hope and then basically
did a couple of days on top of that and
got 400 million now this is the only
time where Luke calls him Obi-Wan
instead of Ben Kenobi Ben was the name
he knew him as but this is showing that
he's now detached from him due to the
lies about his father now we could to
home one where we meet mon mothma
alongside mon calamari Legend Admiral
Akbar this ship ended up returning in
Ahsoka with mothma also returning in the
same room as the hologram this table has
been used several times throughout the
expanded lore to plot out and plan
attacks and it is nice going back to the
scene and seeing where it all began
how'd Emma Crowley who plays General
Nadine he apparently showed up to the
set with a shaved face to the script not
specifying that he had to have a beard
however the Canada based on him that had
been given one unless they quickly
grabbed a fake one to match his action
figure setting out we get Hans saying he
feels he's never gonna see the Falcon
again and originally there were plans
that they were going to destroy it this
would kill off Lando and also pay off on
Han's bad feeling though Lano promised
not a scratch not a scratch it got out
was just losing its satellite dish which
they somewhat touched upon in Solo
during that when it was under land I was
ownership it had a flat dish on top so
he didn't really compensate with that
when flying through the trench now the
third Act was also going to take place
on the Imperial home planet called had
abdon with his letter being renamed to
well you guessed it Cora set this was
Lucas taking inspiration from June with
the hawk on in home planet appearing in
that and we instead we cut the emperor's
throne room on the Death Star 2 and
Vader asks what are the reports of the
Rebel feet massing near Celeste a
Celeste was actually named Napper Roman
Senator and in the expanded law nian Nam
was from the planet and he stole the
shuttle at the rebels right in tying
these lines to that in case you don't
know nietnam's Lando's co-pilot with him
speaking kikuya a language that actually
pulls directly from Kenya we also see
the emperor's advisors who would go on
to form the Imperial Council in the wake
of his death now Endor actually comes
from the Bible with it being a village
found in Israel King Saul went there
before his final battle with the
Philistines and he came across someone
known as The Witch of Endor as the group
leave the shuttle we can catch a bearded
Commando who later pops up disguised as
a scout trooper when they get caught
retroactively it's been said that this
is Captain Rex the legendary clone
trooper from the Clone Wars in Rebels we
then get the Speeder Bike Chase in this
layer's middle switch is pulled back and
this is what's used to jam their
communique locations now according to
IMDb trivia the point of view shots
you're achieved pretty easily with a
cameraman walking through the forest
holding a Steadicam that shot one frame
per second playing this back at 24
frames per second It sped the footage up
and it made it appear at normal speed
giving this the feeling of whizzing
through the forest now the sound of the
Speeders themselves were actually
created by using stock sound effects to
thunder which would then splice together
with a P-38 airplane now the layer comes
off she meets none other than Wicket the
Ewok played by Warwick Davis this guy's
became a Mainstay in Star Wars with them
being in almost all the movies that
follow this both in and out of costume
Warwick went on to play Willow and if
you haven't seen Life's too short with
them then I'd definitely recommend that
you check that out that's why Rick he's
just going there oh yeah yeah we
actually were together on Star Wars The
Phantom Menace oh yeah yeah we had a
scene together it was Cutler do you
remember okay Kenny Baker AKA R2D2 was
originally meant to play Wicket but
Destiny stepped in and gave him the
joining the cast was one Rick Davis who
was just a youngster at the time but
also a die-hard Star Wars fan I was an
11 year old boy at school
and my grandmother happened to hear a
radio commercial on the London radio
station and they were putting out a call
for short people to be in this new Star
Wars movie
I don't think anybody on the movie was
quite as excited as I was you know being
an 11 year old on the Star Wars set
there was there was no stopping me in
the role of wicked Davis became the
film's most prominently featured Ewok
but only after Kenny Baker was suddenly
taken ill I had this scene with Carrie
and the speeder bikes
in in California in the Redwoods
and I'm looking forward to this other
one that carries nice I like working
with Carrie come the morning of the
shoot Kenny was very ill in bed with
what I believe was food poisoning I was
seriously in in pain and um said well
we've got to do it because we've got
Carrie Fisher and we've got the scene
set up
so Warwick took over 72a take two amb
camera don't forget I had a dog at the
time and I remember whenever he would
hear a strange noise he would tilt his
head from side to side uh to look
inquisitive and I took those kind of
movements and and used them in the
character so whenever he sees something
or hears a strange sound he would you
know tilt his head
kind of wild knowing how much work had
gone to work with lucasfilm and wickets
of course one of the most memorable new
characters in the film and the name
Ewoks based on the Native American tribe
Miwok and although they get a lot of
they actually carry an important
message thematically throughout the
entire film and I think they're in there
to really show that you don't need
technology you need the will and the
belief to to take you through anything
uh and the fact that you know the Ewoks
were able to defeat the Empire only
using ropes and rocks I think that said
something about them as a race of
creatures
spiders doesn't matter how much
Machinery you hear
this
if the will of the people is strong they
will always win you failed your highness
I am a Jedi
like my father before me and actually
foreign
if you love CGI blink set it in you'll
love them too and to be honest I've
never really had a problem with these
these cute little fuzzballs now from
here we could divide a meeting with the
emperor and can catch his Red praetorian
Gods and the name comes from ancient
Rome and these tended to be skilled
Warriors who were too tasked with
guarding Empress as well also little
tidbit when designing the throne and
window behind it Lucas said that he
wanted it to appear web-like at the
center of it is the Emperor who would
resemble a spider waiting for a prey to
get caught in its net webs are traps at
spider's bill for their prey and the
entire Emperor's plan is devised as a
trap
[Music]
this is seen with Luke the space battle
and Endor all being designed to catch
these key factions the Death Star is
actually fully operational and thus the
entire schemes devised to get everyone
in one place now that line it's a trap
it was originally it's a trick but this
was changed after it got purely and test
screenings Avada then manages to sense
his son or as the emperor doesn't
strange that I am not
this shows that he's blinded to the
connection Vader has with his kid and
it's ultimately is how the pair beat him
in the end at this point they get caught
in an air with a dead animal luring out
Chewbacca this actually has the back end
of a white-tailed deer with fake teeth
stuck into its butt which is a nice
little bit of trivia for you guys
watching at home I'm believing 3PO is a
God we actually have a translation for
what one of the Ewok says
set in ewokis this actually translates
to that guy's wise could you could you
tell and the take into the Ewok Camp to
get eaten but Luke uses the force to
show his magic so that these little
murderous Bears don't make a barber
Chewbacca and also says
really bad feeling about this which is a
line that's been said in every movie so
far I got a bad feeling about this I
have a bad feeling about this I have a
bad feeling about this also also like
the video and subscribe yeah hurry up
well yeah I haven't got all day now Luke
reveals the Leia that he's her brother
and she recounts stories of her mother
we know in that respect that like I
don't I don't know how you remember this
but there were actually early things in
the script that would be worked in to
become Padme in the first draft she
talked about how her mother disguised as
a handmade which she of course adopted
during Phantom Menace Alex surrenders
and appeals to Anakin rather than Vader
because he knows that's the way that he
has to get through to him rather than
going in to confront him like how he did
last time he instead hands over his
weapon and gives up willingly this is
the lesson that Luke learned from the
cavan Empire and in that Yoda told him
Only what to take with you
had Luke gone in an arm then he would
have been okay but he took his weapons
and went looking for a fight this is
what happened with the jewel at the end
because he went looking for a jewel in
both instances and that's exactly what
he found this time he's going in to
appeal to his dad directly which is why
instead of fighting they first talk it
out allowing Anakin to hold the Jedi
lightsaber once more this may make him
remember exactly what it was like I
always felt there was a deeper meaning
to how he held it and studied it and
this is likely brought back memories of
his time with the order however he turns
his back and delivers what's easily the
most personal and vulnerable moment that
we've seen with beta so far
too late for me son I feel like I'm
saying it's too late for him is him also
thinking about how it's not too late for
Luke and the pair calling each other
father and son now connects them on a
more personal level Luke has actually
based this around the conflicts of Zeus
and his father Chronos Which pull
directly from the myths of ancient
Greece beta also refers to the emperor's
Master a lot and he's very much a slave
almost begging to be freed I always feel
like Lucas had it planned out exactly
what its origin story was but even if he
didn't we we do see through his life how
he start off as a slave and then ended
up being brought into a life of
servitude before he was once more made a
slave Again Luke is the only one who can
truly free him and it laces this moment
with a lot of extra subtext now we end
with him looking out over the forest
again and it shows aside tomb that we've
never really seen before across Endo
we've seen Ewok stealing a bike and we
watch Han getting handy to get his way
in now if you look outside as they enter
you can actually see a rebel dress
putting a helmet on come when the rebels
get caught later on we see my guy Rex
standing in a scout uniform showing that
some of the good guys were disguised as
them during the fight now inside
throwing something at a guard and at
this moment we get what sounds like a
Wilhelm scream
[Music]
foreign
now this is something that's appeared
throughout the Star Wars saga with it
being used in almost every film the guy
making the sound here is actually sound
designer Ben Burt who popularized the
scream whilst also conning the name for
it he's used it in a number of different
movies that he worked on and this is him
doing his best impression of what it
sounds like
[Music]
now we go to the battle out in space and
see both a-wings and b-wings added to
the fleet a-wings originally had blue
paint on them instead of red but this
got lost against the blue screen and
thus they had to change it however when
they showed up in the first episode of
Ahsoka they were back to being blue
because they were no longer relying on
models and blue screens realizing the
shield is still fully operational
the rebel Fleet pull away from their run
and head right into the Star Destroyer
Fleet back with the group on Endor there
saved by Ewoks and then the fight it
just it just kicks off we then hear
Chewbacca's Tarzan yell
and can also catch a cameo by director
Richard Marquand is one of the atsd
drivers there is co-producer Richard
watts and the roof of the atsds actually
have a design based on German Tiger
tanks from World War II they have big
blast marks on the nose of the chewbacca
one and this at least gives the audience
the heads up of who we should be
following after layers shot in the
shoulder we also get a brief moment
where Han has to move his hand because
he goes to grab it but realizes it's on
fire now back with the emperor he
finally turns Luke enough to get him to
strike which is immediately blocked by
Vader looking back I just view this as
him reacting quickly but I actually
think there's a deeper meaning going on
with this as the emperor says if he
strikes him down his journey to the dark
side will be complete and thus if he
landed this he would become a Sith this
would be because he struck him down in
anger and it would become a path that
he'd never be able to walk away from
however Vader blocking this is him
stopping his son from making that
mistake and thus he doesn't succumb to
the dark side and can remain in the
light during the duel Luke kicks right
around the stairs which is a flip on the
battle and best spin in which he did the
same thing to him lots of these moments
in this fight Echo that deal during that
but this time it's Luke who has the
upper hand Bader says
and hey look man's got The High Ground
back on indoor we see his hand tricks
the Imperials to going outside and he
does a little shrug that kylo would
later Riff on in the rise of Skywalker
setting the charges they blow the
generator allowing those in space to
finally attack the Death Star in the
shadows Luke ends up hiding out and we
see Darkness covering his face showing
that he could end up succumbing to the
dark side if he's not careful
symbolically This was later used in The
Saga when Anakin's return brought across
the same technique as well like his
father lovers used to lure him towards
the dark side and it's only upon his
sister being mentioned that he begins to
go on the attack he plays into the
emperor's trap managing to beat his dad
and cut off his hand but in this he's
starting to lose himself now it's very
much a reversal of the ending of Empire
with him starting to realize he's
becoming the man his father is staring
at his own hand he then tosses his
weapon which again was used when a cell
cap passed the test with Anakin I'll try
to stop bringing all this stuff up but
it's just fresh in my mind I do like
talking about how these movies influence
things down the line because yeah you
can see how it's sort of like poetry
they rhyme the emperor realizes that
he's lost and that Luke can't be turned
which is when he decides that he has to
die beta says no which was added into
the special editions to tie losing Padme
to potentially also losing their child
during the scene in which red lifts
pulps above his head we can also see
electricity charging his skeleton and
can actually catch metallic Parts in his
body throwing him down into the Death
Star reactor he was never seen again and
never no way somehow did Palpatine
return at this moment Williams also
plays the Jedi theme over the top of
Vedas to highlight the characters come
back to the light Lucas would actually
pull several moments from this for the
finale of phantom menace as Darth Maul
sent down the hole much like how
Palpatine was there's also a similar
shot used for Obi-Wan cradling a dying
Qui-Gon much like how Luke cradles his
father here he also had the Jedi funeral
at the end before the celebration and
looking back it's sort of like poetry
they rhyme and this we can see the fire
burning stronger on the right side of
the helmet which is why in later
appearances it's more melted on that
side now this scene was actually thrown
in at the last minute with it being
filmed up in the hills next to Skywalker
Ranch and where his breathing then
changes to become weakened and we see
him later on masked for the first time
originally David prowse was promised he
could finally get a show his face in
this moment but Lucas went back on it
due to some strain onset relationships
lots of leaks about the movies had come
out over the years and it was suspected
that prowse had been behind them this is
why Lucas refused to tell him the true
twist during Empire and instead script
he had said oh he won't kill his father
in the build up to the returns release
the Daily Mail also ran a story
revealing that Darth Vader was gonna die
at the end and it had suggested that
prowse was behind it and thus he was
kind of shut out from appearing in the
film he wasn't interviewed for the DVD
release of the original trilogy and he
did carry the reputation of being behind
the leaks however it was revealed that
it was actually a crew member who did
this which kind of sucks when you look
back at it fake scripts were actually
sent out once more to cast members to
dissuade them from spoiling stuff and
some of the leaks contained elements
that had Lando being The Last Hope a
Sebastian Shaw was brought unaware of
what he was filming and upon arriving on
set he had no idea what was happening
until he spotted his old friend Ian
McDermott sure originally had eyebrows
as well when he was in Mass but these
were removed to keep it more consistent
with his Burns now the cut in his head
was also explained in later duels with
his mask getting split during Obi-Wan in
Rebels kinda pick your poison with that
but I love how the unmasked King scene
shows better in a human way that we've
never really seen before all that we've
encountered is this robotic silhouette
but this shows him as a man rather than
just a machine now the net star is
destroyed at this point with both wedge
and Lando delivering the killing blows I
love how all the Superstar Destroyer
gets taken down and people start
celebrating we see his Akbar just kind
of Mourns those that had to die and it's
such an almost like like a way off his
shoulders saying that the fight was
actually worth it at the time the battle
on Endor was the most expansive space
fight ever put to screen and in order to
fill up the background lots of things
like the ships in the distance were
actually just chewed up gum based on
operation chastise this was adapted in
the movie The Dam Busters which Lucas
based a lot of the aerial attacks on in
Chasta is a group of technicians to
write bouncing bombs that would skim
along riverbeds and eventually headed
down in order to destroy it these
scientists were known as buffins and
this is the time that it popularized the
term now Lucas actually gave this a
notice as well with a spies who got the
plans for the Death Star 2 being called
bothans now I Duggan I dug into some of
the behind the scenes stuff and there
was apparently a day called Black Friday
in which 100 000 feet of film was
apparently done by Lucas this was
because it couldn't be read by an
optical printer and the ilm team behind
it had to go back to square one for it a
lot of them got drunk when they heard
the news now back on Endor we watched
the scene that might have been altered
the most over the last couple of years
originally this had a completely
different score
thank you
[Music]
which was later updated into this
Lucas also added in celebrations across
the Galaxy with Coruscant being one that
appeared in the special editions always
remember seeing this back in 1997 and
wondering what was going on because
Coruscant actually hadn't been fully
shown to us at this point in our lives
this had a statue the emperor being
toppled over with us also getting a shot
of Tatooine this was then updated in
2004 with the Senate and Jedi Temple
buildings appearing Anna's also getting
Naboo dropped into there as well lastly
the force ghosts were changed with
Hayden actually completely unaware of
what he was filming he's gone on to say
that he would have played it differently
but it does kind of feel like they just
dropped him into the scene without him
actually being a part of it kind of
makes no sense as well because Luke
wouldn't recognize this well but I'm not
going to go into it I think my my
thoughts on it would be very obvious to
you also I've always kind of been like
there's no way Obi-Wan and Yoda would be
standing there or all friendly like with
Anakin he murdered all our mates and
billions of people and they basically
standing oh yeah you're right mate
you're back oh nice to see you again it
would be like bumping into Hitler in the
afterlife and being like Oh how's it
going mate how's it going you would you
would tell a lot to right off
there's no way that the Mace Windu Force
ghost doesn't see him and kick the
complete out of him
[Laughter]
now they did go back and forth on how to
end the film and in some drafts Luke
would actually take Vader's helmet after
the unmasking we'd watch him put it on
and this would give the idea that he'd
in fact turn to the dark side according
to Gary Kurtz there were also versions
where he'd walk off alone like a
spaghetti western hero with him going
into seclusion in the Tatooine desert in
the end Lucas opted for a happier ending
due to him feeling like merchandise
sales would be boosted by closing on a
positive note
foreign
of the Jedi which would gone to become
the highest grossing movie of 1983 off
the back of its 32 million budget it
banked 418 million with the additional
releases taken it to 475. after its
release they dropped two Ewoks spin-off
movies called Caravan of Courage and the
battle for Endor which
the lesson about the bear doubt we're
going to be doing a classic movie
breakdown for those pieces of
however it's undeniable how much of a
success this film series was and this
original trilogy still stands as an
outstanding achievement Lucas went
against the studios to make one of the
biggest film franchises of all time and
it has to be said it captured the
imagination of billions now that wraps
up our original trilogy breakdown and
huge thank you to everyone who's checked
out this series extra shout out to the
members who pledge money to the channel
every week and it goes such a long way
to helping videos like this get made if
you want to support us then please click
the join button and as a thank you
you'll get access to videos like this
every week the second we get them edited
now if you want something else to watch
then make sure you check out our
Brighton of Starship Troopers on screen
right here right or right up in the
corner or maybe it's below over the next
couple of weeks we have a lot that we're
covering as well and we're gonna aim to
drop videos on Apocalypse Now the thing
prequel Terminator 3 and a lot more you
go breakdowns on gen V A Soca and
potentially The Exorcist 3 to look
forward to as well so make sure you guys
stay locked to the channel by the way
huge thank you for clicking this I've
been poor and I'll see you next time
take care peace